encuentra la pendiente de la línea
mostrada en la gráfica
repasando muy realmente la pendiente
simplemente nos está diciendo que tanto
está inclinada la línea recta el mejor
modo de escribirlo es pendiente es igual
al cambio en que en cambio la coordenada
y dividido entre el cambio en la
coordenada x cambio en x y para una
línea recta
este valor siempre nos da una constante
a veces lo escribimos con este pequeño
triangulito que significa cambio en es
una letra griega delta mayúscula y es
cambio en g
/ cambio en x así que veamos cuál es el
cambio de ya que le corresponde algún
cambio en x y vamos a considerar ahorita
puntos que sean muy sencillos de ubicar
en esta gráfica así que empecemos por
acá mejor con otro color
empezamos en este punto
y queremos ir a otro punto que sea fácil
de ubicar digamos a este punto de aquí y
podríamos saber en realidad elegido
cualesquiera dos puntos que quisiéramos
en esta gráfica
pero bueno cuál es el cambio en respecto
al cambio en x empezamos con el cambio
en x así que en realidad en x nos
movimos de aquí a acá y me cambio en x
entonces es d
una unidad dos unidades tres unidades
así que el cambio en x vale 3
y también lo podríamos ver desde las
coordenadas me moví desde la coordenada
menos 3 hasta la coordenada 0 así que me
cambio en x es de 3 unidades positivas
delta de equis estrés
y cuál es mi cambio y pues me cambio en
sí
es de -3 hasta 1 negativo o sea que es
de 2 pero vamos a hacerlo de este modo
mi cambio es de
una unidad dos unidades entonces es dos
unidades positivas así que cuál es mi
cambio en entre mi cambio en x pues
cuando me me cambió en x fue de 3 me
cambio de jeff fue 2 y esto es
precisamente la pendiente
y como les dije podría haber elegido
cualesquiera dos puntos sobre esta recta
y siempre obtendría el mismo valor
digamos empecemos de nuevo y ahora voy a
elegir otros dos puntos e incluso voy a
ir en otra dirección supongamos que
ahora empiezo acá y ahora me muevo hasta
este punto de aquí
vamos ahora a pensar en el cambio y cuál
es mi cambio y empecé aquí y me moví
hacia abajo cuántas unidades
me moví 1 2 3 4 unidades así que me
cambio en que es de -4 porque empecé en
el 1 y bajé hasta la coordenada menos 3
en las 10 así que mi cambio es igual a
menos 4 y cuál es mi cambio en x pues
empecé en este lugar de la equis
y me moví todo este camino hacia la
izquierda así que el cambio es negativo
y me moví 1 2 3 4 5 6 unidades
así que me cambio en x es de menos 6
porque me movía a la izquierda así que
mi delta x es menos 6
porque empecé en x igual a 3 y me moví
hasta x igual a menos 3 así que el
cambio total es de menos 6 recuerden que
veo muy bien la izquierda así que cuánto
vale mi cambio en entre mi cambio en x
pues es igual a menos 4 entre menos 6 y
los menos se cancelan y lo que me queda
es 2 entre tres así que obtengo el mismo
valor sólo hay que ser consistentes aquí
empecé y bajé 4 y después retrocede 6
así que es menos 4 entre menos 6 y ahora
considero que empieza en este punto de
acá abajo entonces primeros hubo 4 así
que mi cambio es de 4 y después me
cambió en x es de 6 porque avance
así que de nuevo tengo mi cambio en / me
cambió en x 4 en 36 que es dos tercios
así que no importa donde empiecen solo
hay que ser consistente con las
direcciones y nos dará el mismo valor